microsoft have announced the price cut
for the xbox one right here in the UK as
of this friday 28 us cheeky brits can
pick one up for 399 pounds and 99 pets
that's a slash of 30 pounds off the
original recommended retail price just
three months after launch for wee bit of
context predecessor console the Xbox 360
had to wait nearly a year for its first
price reduction speaking to gain spot
Xbox UK marketing director Harvey eagle
confirmed that the company currently has
no plans to cut the price in other
territories the Xbox one currently
retails for 499 dollars in the US which
is roughly 300 pounds as part of the
price gap Microsoft will also sell its
freshly unveiled limited edition
titanfall bundle in the UK at the new
price of 399 pounds and ninety nine
pence included in said bundle is a
standard black xbox one the connect a
wireless controller wired headset a
download code for titanfall and a one
month xbox live gold subscription the
included controller is not however the
limited edition titanfall controller but
the machine does come in some fancy
titanfall packaging mmm very boxy to
celebrate the launch of type before we
wanted to do something special said xbox
exec use of Medi for those of you who
are already fans of Xbox one we hope
this will encourage more of your friends
to join you on day one for titanfall on
xbox one so will this price cut persuade
any of you to pick up an Xbox one with
titanfall this Friday let us know in the
comments down below and for more on this
story and anything else in the world of
video games stay tuned to gamespot com